el maestro de scarlett johansson les dio
un sistema de ecuaciones lineales para
resolver cada uno realizó algunos pasos
que condujeron a los sistemas que se
muestran en la tabla de abajo y observa
que aquí tenemos el sistema de
ecuaciones del maestro por acá el
sistema de ecuaciones de scarlett y por
acá el sistema de ecuaciones de hans
scholl cuál de ellos obtuvo un sistema
equivalente al sistema del maestro y
aquí está la palabra clave equivalente
que es que un sistema es equivalente
bueno recuerda que dos sistemas lineales
son equivalentes si tienen la misma
solución es decir que si nosotros nos
tomamos un paro ordenado x y que sea
solución de este sistema para que éste
es equivalente del maestro debe de tener
el mismo parc x james que sea solución
del sistema y de igual manera para hans
scholl así que buscamos una equis jeff
que satisfaga este sistema y para que
scarlett tenga un sistema equivalente
entonces debemos de tener la misma
solución
y veamos si podemos concluir esto para
scarlett
esto es interesante mira su segunda
ecuación es 14 x menos 7 james igualados
y la segunda ecuación del profesor es 14
x menos 7 y igual a 7 tienen una razón
igual entre x y ya tienen una razón
igual pero su término constante es
diferente en este caso es 2 y en este
caso es 7 y esto es muy interesante y
tengo que hacer la aclaración de que
estos sistemas el del maestro y el de
scarlett no van a tener la misma
solución y me dirás cómo puedo concluir
eso bueno es que estas dos ecuaciones si
las escribimos en la forma pendiente
ordenada de origen verías como la razón
entre xy que es la misma es decir vamos
a tener la misma pendiente pero
tendremos diferentes intersecciones con
el eje y de hecho para poder resolverlas
vamos a hacer esto y graficar las esta
de aquí como nos va a quedar
si restamos 14 x de ambos lados nos va a
quedar menos 7 james es igual a este va
a pasar del otro lado con signo negativo
menos 14 x + 7 positivo y luego pues
dividimos todo entre menos 7 que me va a
quedar me va a quedar que james es igual
a menos 14 entre menos 7 estos dos 2x
menos 1 es decir lo único que hice fue
manipularla de una manera algebraica y
si ahora tomamos a esta ecuación y la
dibujamos como una recta que me va a
quedar
bueno pues sacamos dos ejes por aquí
tengo un eje por aquí me voy a tomar al
otro eje por acá y entonces que me va a
quedar si gráfico esta recta que tengo
aquí
bueno pues date cuenta que cortamos al
eje y en el valor de menos 1 así que
supongamos que este es el valor de menos
1 y tenemos una pendiente de 2 por lo
tanto se va a ver más o menos así mi
recta se va a ver más o menos
más o menos de esta manera esta sería mi
primer recta es decir estábamos
trabajando con esta de aquí y que era
esta de aquí recuerdas y qué pasa si
trabajamos ahora con la segunda ecuación
pero de scarlett bueno ahora voy a
trabajar con esta de aquí y si te das
cuenta lo primero que voy a hacer es lo
mismo restar 14 x de ambos lados y me
voy a quedar con menos 7 james igual a
menos 14 x menos 14 x más 2 positivo y
si ahora lo que hago es dividir todo
entre menos 7 me va a quedar que james
es igual a menos 14 entre menos 7 es 22
x menos dos séptimos es decir que esta
ecuación la puedo representar con la
siguiente línea recta
tengo una intersección con el eje 10 de
menos dos séptimos que eso va a estar
más o menos como por aquí y tengo la
misma pendiente es decir que se va a ver
de la siguiente manera tengo esta recta
lo bueno de ser lo más parecido posible
me va a quedar esta recta de verde es
decir que voy a tener la misma pendiente
pero diferente intersección con el eje
james lo que quiere decir que estas dos
rectas son paralelas así que cada
coordenada que satisfaga el sistema del
profesor en definitiva no va a
satisfacer el de scarlett estas dos
ecuaciones no tienen puntos en común
porque bueno son paralelas es decir
justo esta es la definición de paralelas
así que si ésta y ésta no tienen puntos
en común por lo tanto no hay forma de
que exista una solución que satisfaga el
sistema del profesor y que satisfaga el
sistema de scarlett porque cualquier x
ye que satisfaga la segunda ecuación del
profesor en definitiva no va a
satisfacer la segunda de scarlett o
viceversa porque son paralelas pero que
scarlett no tienen un sistema
equivalente al del profesor y qué va a
pasar con hanson bueno pues te puedes
dar cuenta que con jan sólo va a pasar
parecido tenemos aquí 5 x menos en la
primera ecuación dejar sol y en la
primera actuación del maestro tenemos 5
x menos 10 y date cuenta que el término
constante es diferente aquí tengo 3 y
aquí tengo menos 6 por lo tanto la
primera ecuación del profesor y la
primera ecuación dejan sol son rectas
paralelas y entonces cada equis y que
satisfaga la primera actuación del
maestro en definitiva no va a satisfacer
la primera ecuación de hanson no hay
manera
y entonces estas dos rectas no se
interceptan ambas son paralelas así que
el sistema de hanson tampoco es
equivalente al del maestro